this was November 17th of last year when
Chris Mannix who covers the sport of
boxing as well as the NBA and I asked
him about the possibility of a Conor
McGregor Floyd Mayweather fight here's
Chris Mannix I've talked to people in
the divided Commission that's where the
fight would probably be in Las Vegas
there are people in that Commission who
have said we're not going to sanction
this why would we sanction of a boxing
match between the best boxer in the
world and a guy that's never boxed
before in his life so put this people
should put this idea out of their heads
because it's just never going to happen
let's bring in Chris Mannix from Yahoo
Sports the vertical how did we get from
there to here Chris
well I'd first like to point out Dan
that outside of my time in bars every
bad life decision has been recorded on
the show yeah you know they'd be we got
here largely because of the pile of
money
and I don't have any respect by the way
for the Nevada Commission for for
sanctioning this I mean I saw some of
the quotes from bob bennett the
executive director of the Nevada
Commission saying that there was you
know the film they've watched of
McGregor shows you can box me give me a
break I mean this is this should be an
exhibition not a truly sanctioned fight
and the Commission should be embarrassed
for doing it but we're here because
there's just too much money on the table
for either one of these fighters to pass
this up I mean this is a fight that's
probably going to and I say this
incredulous ly but going to eclipse two
to three million pay-per-view buys and
make these guys in the neighborhood of
seventy-five to a hundred million
dollars that's exclusively why we're
here all right you can't say that
McGregor doesn't have a chance because
he's in the ring and you know he so he
does have a chance he has a chance to at
least knock him out how would you assess
though just the boxing skills of Conor
McGregor than what you've seen I mean
the word rudimentary comes to mind when
I think of McGregor's boxing skills
there's a video circulating out there if
I'm sparring that is you know pretty
awful and let's remember I mean
everything about this fight is a boxing
match he's going to be wearing ten ounce
gloves he's used to wearing those
4-ounce pads he's got to go the full 12
rounds in this fight he's used to
fighting five and for the most part it's
it's a lot of his fights have gone a lot
shorter I mean he's going to enter an
entirely new world and look I mean I'd
I'd push back then on the narrative that
that can't we he can't win he can't win
I mean that's it would take in my
opinion an act of God or from aggregor
to win this fight they would have to be
like a torn ACL for mayweather in the
first round even then I'd still probably
favor Floyd fighting on one ACL he is
just he's entering a world that is a
complete unknown to him and everything
that made him a great UFC fighter is
virtually irrelevant in a fight like
this Seaton we were recording on that
right yeah we were we got it yeah just
going up yeah just want to make just a
little work you record first of all
space stack I mean they're attaining
names going to be great in the
three-on-three by the way they are
looking forward yeah they are but but he
has a chance you can't say he has no
chance you might not like him as a boxer
I mean did you have a chance but like
what okay
what percentage in let's play that even
if it's 1% if it's a tenth of 1% he has
a chance
what is this Dumb and Dumber like yes
yes you're telling me there's a chance
okay you're the one that said it would
never happen and I said follow the money
in these these two sports so right you
know that the biggest surprise to me and
had looked at when I talk to people
yesterday about how this negotiation
came together they said it was
remarkably fast at the deal points and
the money once they were sat down and
actually negotiated came together fast
and the reason they're doing this on
August 26th then is because you know ox
26 is a bad pay-per-view date you know
usually boxing you never see a big
boxing promotion in the summer time
because they think people have better
things to do on Saturday nights in the
summer then stay in and watch a fight
the reason they're doing this so fast is
because they don't want to give the
public anymore time to realize what's in
fighting it's like a guy going in Vegas
you know it's like a guy going to Vegas
and getting married on a whim and he
does it because he doesn't want to have
to think about it realized he's making a
bad decision the people that are going
to put $100 down this fight if you
agnus out to October November and it
continues getting just pureed in the
media as it will over the next couple of
months they don't want to give people
more time to think about how bad a fight
this is going to be so they put this on
they're rushing out the front door and
they want to make this thing happen
before people realize that this is a
gross utter mismatch is it bad for
boxing bad for MMA both Niva I don't
know I mean I I don't know if it's bad I
do think that it's disappointing largely
and I can only speak from a boxing
perspective that there are so many
fighters that I'd like to see Mayweather
fight against I mean I'd you could
probably sell me in the next six months
or so on a rematch with Pacquiao just
because patios bought pretty well I'm
not saying it's the same fight ban I'm
not saying it's you don't have to make
it a hundred dollars or whatever but I
could you could sell me on that there
are other guys not to get to wonkish but
like he Thurman arrow spends like sign
me up for those fights as a boxing fan
this is going after the casual this is
going after the circus fan guys that
they'd love to see that the complete you
know the Zayn eNOS of these press
conference this is who this is targeting
and this is who this is going disappoint
he's Chris Mannix Yahoo Sports the
vertical covers the NBA and boxing
senior writer alright let's look at the
draft coming up next week I'm not sold
on the Celtics with marquel folds it
just feels like there and I know
smokescreens this is where we start to
see them not see through them maybe but
what do you think happens at the top and
then as we work our way down to second
third pick I'd be really surprised if
it's anybody but folks and I'm basing
that you know Danny Ainge obviously he's
a wild card you don't know what he
position he could make kind of
unilaterally but you know in the months
prior to to the trivia the lottery this
even before Boston knew they're going to
have the number one pick when I'm
talking to the scouts there and
executives in the organization they were
just effusive in their praise of folks
they think he is a transcendent once
every 10 years type of point guard so
based on that information I think he's
going to go number one and what number
two you know the Lakers better remember
who's running the Lakers on the
day-to-day its Magic Johnson at the top
the Rob
polenka is a former agent Rob palanca is
you know agents during this process they
love to throw Chum in the water and just
you know and see what happens and Rob
pálinka and I think the Lakers are
putting out some misdirection out there
they're they're letting people know
though Josh Jackson Darren Fox the
workout for Lonzo ball wasn't very good
I'm not believing any of it I think
they'd like to see if a team like you
know Sacramento is that nuts that they
might try to move up and make a
blockbuster deal or somebody else I
still believe that what I heard in the
early stages of this process that magic
Johnson loved Lonzo ball that he wants
Lonzo ball that that still remains the
same I think ball is going to be the
number two pick yeah I do too but I
think Magic's looking at this is a
businessman you know that he's falling
in love with the business side of Lonzo
ball and what he'll mean because people
will show up to watch him people tuned
in to watch him with you on that Jerry
West to the Clippers and we were
wondering this prior to the start of the
show when Jerry was last on the show a
couple of weeks ago you could hear it
you can hear it his voice he wanted to
finish with the Lakers why was that door
closed well I don't know why it was
closed necessarily I just don't think
the Lakers had a need for him you know
magic coming in revamping the the
personnel obvious I think Jerry sort of
helped anything including the Lakers as
an advisor I just don't think the Lakers
felt like they had a need for them at
that time the Clippers I mean I look I I
love Jerry West there but it's not like
Jerry West can create more cap spaces in
fact the drafting that the Clippers have
trade the way I'd be hesitant to think
that in almost 80 year old Jerry West
can be able to perform miracles there
but in the case of the Lakers
you know maybe not needing Jerry West
the Clippers do I mean the Clippers have
a relatively young inexperienced
front-office
Lawrence Frank is the GM he went from
being a coach I think Jerry was going to
add valuable experience and Intel in
trying to rebuild some of the things
with it within this team so I like to
fit a lot for him there I'll leave you
with this the player who will not be
back with his team most likely not back
with his team let's say Blake Griffin
let's say
Kevin Love Jimmy Butler Gordon Hayward
Paul George well let me turn this around
on your dad and ask you this question do
you think that Gordon Hayward's wife
posted that Instagram of her the kid
wearing a shamrock t-shirt by accident
no no I don't either I think that the
Brad Stevens connection with Hayward is
strong I think the Eastern Conference is
appealing if I had to guess one of those
players I would say Gordon Hayward goes
east and plays for Boston Kevin Love on
the move first of all if Indiana is not
trading Paul George for Kevin Love that
makes zero sense for the Pacers
if they're going to trade Paul George
it's for rebuilding package that
includes young players and draft picks
why with the Pacers want 28 year-old
Kevin Love on a max contract
I think Kevin Love will be dangled and
deals but are you really going to get
something back that the equivalent of
Kevin Love that's something I'm unless
you're about have fun in Vegas and will
once again play this sound for you
probably after the fight for the rest of
my life for the rest of your life we're
always recording your life Chris thank
you back again that's Chris Mannix you
know who sports the vertical the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience